lamari humaine aura duré une journée
entière à pied par la plage ou à la nage
par la mer et aidé parfois de bouées
gonflables ou canot pneumatique des
femmes et hommes de tous âges dont
certains très jeunes ont atteint
l'enclavé espagnole de ceuta
depuis le maroc voisin avec parfois ces
drames dans la journée un homme est mort
en se noyant
au total au moins 6000 franchissement
illégaux de frontières ont été
enregistrés du jamais vu
je suis venu ici pour traverser
clandestinement pour assurer l'avenir de
mon fils car ici à tétouan il n'y a rien
comme vous le voyez c'est une ville
touristique nous aventurons pour
traverser soit je meurs soit je passe
comme vous le voyez tous les jeunes
veulent quitter le pays
il n'y a pas de travail tu n'as pas peur
de la mer non je n'ai pas peur si je
reste ici j'aurais peur je dois partir
pour sauver ma vie
plus de deux mille sept cent d'entre eux
ont déjà été renvoyée au maroc
selon le ministre espagnol de
l'intérieur il rappelle que les
autorités espagnoles et marocaines ont
conclu récemment un accord concernant le
retour vers leur pays des citoyens
marocains qui arrive à la nage à ceuta
face à la crise le premier ministre
espagnol pedro sanchez a annulé sa
participation au sommet sur le
financement des économies africaines
prévu à paris un afflux de migrants dans
un contexte de tensions diplomatiques
entre les deux pays voisins
avec en toile de fond le conflit au
sahara occidental khabar reproche à
madrid d'accueillir sur son sol le chef
des indépendantistes sahraouis du front
polisario
arrivé fin avril pour se soigner du
coronavirus depuis plus de 45 ans le
conflit dans cette ancienne colonie
espagnole classé territoire non autonome
par les nations unies en
l'absence d'un règlement définitif
oppose le maroc au polisario soutenu par
l'algérie